don't be too obsessed with this whole
state of singing publication a lot of to
waste of time
[Music]
the impact factor really isn't that
important what's important is that you
develop an area of science you make
progressive discoveries and you earn a
reputation for solid work
what counts is really the data any great
paper is going to be found in read to do
good solid work consistently you'll be
recognized
institution have to judge the quality of
a person based on the quality of the
research you shouldn't be relying on
journals and two or three reviews to
judge that I don't merely look oh it is
one in science and two in nature that
means tree so I really do read the
papers
publish as high as is practical don't
waste a whole lot of time making
repeated attempts to get into the top
tier praising the imitators we go to
nature of science the editorial process
can be so protracted with some any
requirement that you end up with a paper
which is totally unreadable you have no
idea what it's about or what these
people are trying to say the reviewers
have turned it into a porridge you don't
want to publish porridge
[Music]